germany is bracing for a rapid spread of
the omicron coronavirus variant with the
variant already in the country the
government is responding by stepping up
its vaccination program and introducing
new restrictions
tight limits on social contacts will
come into effect after christmas
omicron is on the advance in germany and
the politicians say it's time to react
after their meeting chancellor schultz
and the state premiers said private
gatherings would be limited to just 10
people if they're vaccinated or have
recovered from covet
for the unvaccinated socializing will be
even harder they will only be able to
meet two other people the moves are
prompted by fears the virus could spread
over the holidays
i can understand everyone and each of
you who doesn't want to hear any more
about corona about mutations and new
virus variants but we cannot and must
not close our eyes to this next wave
that's beginning to loom over us
corona's not taking a christmas break
despite that most of those buying
last-minute gifts will be able to hand
them over in person on christmas day the
new restrictions will only be compulsory
from the 28th of december
new year is said to be unusually quiet
with sports events played in empty
stadiums and dance venues closed this is
just
this is not the time for parties and
social evenings in large groups
the government is putting hopes on
continuing the high rate of vaccination
through the christmas period they hope
to deliver millions more japs by the end
of the year and 30 million in january
in berlin many people seem unfazed by
the prospect of tougher measures
i hadn't planned anything big anyway
just a small family gathering that's
best we went as a teen
we're 10 people and of course we would
like to celebrate christmas together the
adults are all boosted and i get a pcr
test every other day
so we feel we are on the safe side
six of us will get together with friends
unfortunately without family they're in
stuttgart in munich we don't want to get
on the train and driving's too stressful
so we'll visit them next year
the chancellor says though infections
are currently falling it's only a matter
of time before omicron is the dominant
covet variant in germany
corona has not stolen christmas but the
strain it is putting on the public and
the politicians is not over yet
well for more let's talk to our chief
political correspondent melinda crane
melinda the new measures don't take
effect until after christmas wouldn't
they do more good if introduced right
away
in fact they're not compulsory until
after christmas but some federal states
will be uh instituting them sooner for
example mecklenburg foxcarmen in the
northeast of the country has decided
that as of christmas eve they will be
putting measures into effect because
intensive care bed capacity there is
severely strained so there is some
leeway uh nonetheless uh no question uh
the authorities could have gone further
but the government faces something of a
dilemma terry because the fact is that
infection rates have been falling
recently and until these latest warnings
many people here in germany felt that
things were looking up especially
compared to late november when uh cases
were much much higher but the fact is
that at the moment we're in a lull
between two waves the fourth wave that
was caused by the delta variant is
receding and that fifth wave hasn't hit
yet and that makes it very difficult for
the government to uh essentially get way
out in front with the measures that it
imposes and in fact that was recognized
by the chancellor he said yesterday he's
aware that people are tired people feel
brittle and therefore i think there's a
sense on the part of the government
particularly since the health minister
had said there will be no hard lockdown
before christmas that they need to take
this step by step but they did face some
pushback from the federal states
well state and federal leaders in
germany have disagreed on the best way
to fight the pandemic in the past is
there more consensus this time melinda
outwardly there was consensus
but as i said a couple of federal states
did feel that the measures don't go far
enough
they made that clear in a press
conference following the meetings so
so the blanket of consensus was a bit
thin perhaps these particular states
they include van
gutenberg in the southwest
saxony in the east they're concerned
that the new government hasn't
established the necessary legal
framework for ensuring that in an
emergency uniform measures can be
adopted quickly across all of germany as
you know such a law was in place under
the last government this government
decided to repeal it uh in hope that the
bundestag the legislature would then
have more of a say in the measures that
are established but as i say several
states feel that we don't at the moment
have the necessary legal basis and there
was also quite a heated discussion about
a last minute warning yesterday from the
country's center of disease control
which did in fact advocate a harder
lockdown
well as you mentioned earlier melinda uh
parts of germany
the intensive care units are already
full
how concerned are authorities about the
capacity of the country's healthcare
system to deal with what's coming
they're very very concerned some experts
have said
that omnicon could be the dominant
variant here in germany as early as the
end of january and that we could then
see new cases up to a hundred thousand a
day that will put an absolute strain on
intensive care capacity across this
country as you know in late november
early december some hospitals were
already having to do triage send
patients elsewhere for intensive care
treatment that's one concern the other
concern is essential services like
electricity water
garbage disposal and so on because
we may see many many essential workers
falling out
all right melinda thank you so much our
chief political correspondent melinda
crane
and here's a roundup of some of the
other developments in the pandemic
worldwide
portugal bars and portuguese bars and
restaurants will now close from the 26th
of december five days earlier than
scheduled infections in portugal have
risen sharply despite a vaccination rate
of around 90 percent
israel has announced it will begin
offering a fourth dose of covet 19
vaccine to medical personnel and people
over the age of 60. this comes amid
concerns over the omicron variant and
the eu's covet 19 pass for travel will
now expire
nine months after vaccination unless the
holder has a booster shot the new rule
is due to come into force in february
you